人間誰しもその人が言わないようなセリフ聞いてみたくないですか
聞くそういうギャップにみんな燃えギャップ萌えですねって部門とか普段しないような
んだろう起こらないような人が怒るから強い普段厳しい人が優しくされるから
キュンって言うようにその人が言わないようなことを言わせるとやっぱりいいんですよ
というゲームと右上にいるんですけど
今回はホットとミックさんと素敵な部分札のとミクさんから見れないような綺麗な
普段がきれいじゃねーよな考えもとから汚いから2段のとミクさんが絶対言えないよう
なセリフを言わせてもっとミクさんの素敵な部分をみなさんに知ってもらいたいという
わけで今回の企画はお客さんがいわなさそうなセリフを言わせた瞬間今度が終わります
はいもうそういう客ですで先ほどツイッターの方で少し募集
をかけたんですけどもちょっと色々ありすぎて難しい
送ってくださった皆様ありがとうございます結構いろいろあるんですけども
どこどうかなんだろう同9位はそうだろう
9前にネクステ入り体とかとりあえず上から見たときに一番いけそうなのはとみかぽん
ぽむぷりんここの辺かなトミカとかいうはなさそうですよね御気さくな魚の動画だすで
多分トミカおもちゃなことあんまり言わないと思うんでと民家でないで行ってみたいと
思いますで梅香
ヒューゴ損はこんばん保存袋まだない1ぺー
部分部分一羽分うんざりだいたい会社
ブーンブーンですよはいいいクラブをつくってうん
ああっ
バージョンブーン
ゾーンんん war ii
4 day moon
ですよああああああああ
[音楽]
ねホワイトミックうん
お前の欲しいものは名誉かそれとわーお
それでも艦隊がそれでも
名誉か名誉しからよっちーか
名誉かあと思う
米はチームだねぇ
ええええええ
デュウ問題はいっ
あのユーチューバーて9位大
ん
あの襟足の長いユーチューバーだーらー
水玉リボンとに
野郎0
20たおっですけどどーん
opteron から打ってろやばいよああ
how are you do
っていうのをもっと英語子ギャルて自分
枚目を誘致拾う jun 4
がぜ by 年を得て仮名
別に怯えや嫌韓はね売らねえ豚
むー
うううう多いと思う誰だぞ
[音楽]
ブーブー
遊んでないで準備し本気ですって僕は減る
準備に本気持つもらうといっターン
もし車買ったら沿いの巻きつけますメイン shop さん
対象みたいな最初の車のニックネームです
トミック
はぁ
ポニーちゃう
コーン茶
ポニーちゃん
じゃあ
さあどうすれや
仲良く遊ぶ
みんな僕まっ
あじゃあ膣って言われそう
言ってるってこの三角から3.2くださいでしょ
なおリボンロー集まる
異論が狂う
アド飲んでてこいはたらくくるまッ
って言っ
その役監査もつばにないですね
柴犬みんなの上だったんだと思う
あった
当院の
[音楽]
富1
にっ
たちもうどんどんや指導した例4と同様するん
スぞ
ぶーぶざほ額のブーブ歯車
グーグで遊びたいののだね品をボブだべたい
の日か
[音楽]
me
uh
あっはぁ
うんっ
労働
[音楽]
ん
ふーん
ちょっと地味くすぐったルー